so just real quick I know a lot of
people are asking this question others
are not asking but the number of people
who are asking it makes me think maybe
you have this question but you're just
not asking it so this is C this is C
this is the one with the root 3 net ok
so just have a look I've already done
most of the work for you but I want to
point out some things and then do the
part that I haven't done so here's my
equation here's where I began right you
can see I've got my negative 2 and my 1
hiding in here but they're all opposite
right because it's X take away negative
2 it's Y take away positive 1 so that's
where you get that on the right-hand
side here
why is this 3 and not 9 right so I look
at this and you will get often lots of
nice equations where you'll get like
square numbers over here you're like oh
these are all really lovely right you'll
get used to seeing numbers that you
expect to be squares but they don't have
to be we might give you any number and
the radius would be the square root of
that guy right which in this case they
want to be root 3 ok now I've gone ahead
and drawn it but what you might notice
is not only do I have my Center I know
it's not the most circular circle so run
with me what you've noticed is I
couldn't draw this without reaching for
my calculator and working out route 3 ok
now I happen to actually into roughly
what root 3 is but that's just because
I've done this hundreds of times but you
don't have to because your calculator
will give it to you to enough precision
that you can put this on the graph right
now I know for example it's less than 2
it's closer to you but it's less than 2
so you can see for example here right
this is negative 1 that's where I'm
lined up with right so when I go down
when the radius goes down it's gonna go
one point seven three units down so
there it's gone one unit if I went down
to here I would have gone two units
that's too far I'm not going to go that
far I'm only meant to go one point seven
three units so you can see that's why
I'm a little bit shy of it same deal up
here I'm a bit below you know I can't go
two units I've got to stay a little bit
behind there so that's how I've drawn
this and I've done the same thing here
that distance is 2 so this distance in
here is that 1.73
roughly okay now from here I then have
to think about domain
range and this becomes a little bit
awkward because I have these square
roots so let's think about domain right
my x-values what is the leftmost x value
I get hmm now think about this right
where's the center it's here negative 2
here's the leftmost very how far did I
go to the left yeah I did this that's
how far I went to the left right so I
started at negative 2 and then I went a
further root 3 units to the left
so why subtract root 3 do you see that
so I started at negative 2 and then I
went this way root 3 units that's my
leftmost point okay what about my
rightmost point yeah I start from the
center again but then instead of going
to the left I'm going to the right the
same distance root 3 okay so to the
right means that guy and as we already
established before you can actually get
to these endpoints hence the square
brackets same deal with range square
bracket when I think vertically where my
where's my starting point what value am
i starting out for the center it's it's
one right there it is right when I think
about from one downwards it's one and
then I take away the radius one take
away the root 3 that will send me down
to the bottom most point and then I can
go up to one plus root 3 ok now I know
that looks a bit awful and gross okay
because their cert so they don't
simplify nicely but can you see this
just comes out of what a circle is in
fact these 1 2 3 4 points there were the
kind of anchor points that you drew when
you're making sure your circle was in
the right spots okay once you have a
look at this equation over here on the
right hand side with me okay now this
equation presents to kind of huh moments
right here's the first weird moment
right when you look at the right hand
side it equals 0 neatly hold on a second
the right hand side is supposed to be
like my radius right what kind of circle
is this okay that's the first weird
thing the second weird thing is you can
see every equation you've been dealing
with so far it's in this nice
factorized form right like oh I can look
at this and immediately I can just read
off center is at negative two and one
okay but this is not this is not neatly
factorized and it turns out those two
weirdnesses that's a word there's two
weird aspects of this they're kind of
two sides of the same coin
because in factorizing this left hand
side which you're going to help me do in
a second we will actually fix up and
find out what the radius is so let's
have a think about this at the moment if
I want to turn this into a nice neat
factorized thing the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to try and
gather all of the X's together because
they're eventually going to be together
like this in a factorize thing so I'm
going to write down and don't worry
about Raiders down I promise you'll have
the opportunity a minute when I write
all the X terms together then there's
this Y squared knees over here okay now
what you can end up with is something
squared right a nice neat perfect square
is this some technique we have access to
that allows us to factorize things that
allows them to become a nice perfect
square we will graph this eventually but
before I got to know I've got it I've
got to think about a technique that
we've learned before more in the context
of brothers and quadratics right what do
we do okay so we can add and subtract
something that will allow this thing to
become a square right we call this
because what we're going to wear like
missing a theme don't make these as well
remember we call this completing the
square right what am I going to add yeah
look at this number right I'm gonna have
it and then square it Harvard Square
it's when you have this you get and then
you square it you get 25 okay so I'm
adding 25 in here this is an equation
right you can't just add something
because you want to everything you must
maintain balance so if I added 25 here
since I've got an equation I'm gonna add
25 to the other side said okay all right
now see this guy here this is now a nice
new square right this is X plus 5 all
squared right and this guy here I know
this is going to start a bit look a bit
silly but I'm gonna write it as Y minus
0 squared because Y is y minus 0
why do you think I wrote it in that form
what's useful about it yeah I'm trying
to get it looking like this right so now
off of this I can read off the center
and the radius what are the what's the X
corner center negative five what's the Y
corner zero and then the radius will
equal to the square root of this guy is
five right now that so that completing
the square thing is not just useful for
solving quadratic equations it also
helps us untangle this equation okay can
I give you a minute to get that down and
then we'll have a look at B together
which is slightly more complicated but I
promise just to be able to do it give
you a bit of time to catch up okay this
looks so then we'll complicated it's
only a little more complicated this time
I'm gonna have you do it with me and I'm
gonna be a little more structured and
tell you exactly what I'm doing okay so
see this thing here it's just a garbled
expanded mess it came from here and
someone expanded it it's like why why
did you do that right so I'm gonna undo
that the this step that I'm back to do I
call it kind of prepare for surgery
right I'm not ready to complete the
square yet I've got to arrange this
nicely so it's easier for me to see what
I should do right so here's the first
step and you can do it along with me
right
see these X terms here I'm gonna gather
them I'm also going to gather these Y
terms here I'm gonna gather them
together yeah and then see this guy
right this constant term in the equation
for a circle the constant ends up on the
right hand side it helps me work out my
radius right so I'm gonna gather my X's
I'm gonna gather my Y's and then I'm
gonna kick this guy over here I'm gonna
add it to both sides right so let's do
this step I'm not actually doing any
like fancy rearrangement I'm just saying
here are the X's right I've even gonna
like leave myself a gap because I know
I'm about to add something right here my
Y's right like so X is there Y is there
and then the constants all belong on the
right-hand side so I'm going to add 11
to both sides okay so now I'm ready to
go now in this case you can see I have
not one but two squares to complete and
that's fine you could do both of them in
one here what number do I add two
this part here to complete the X square
so I'm going to have this and then
square it
Harvie it gives me negative 4 square
gives me 16 as soon as you add 16 here
immediately
add 16 to the other side don't like wait
to the end you added 16 here do it at
the same time
okay still balanced and then this guy
here you have this gives you three
square it gives you nine so as soon as
you add 9 here you should also add 9
here everything is balanced okay and if
you like I mean I just kind of like
doing this to myself you're like there's
all the X stuff and here's all the Y
stuff and then I can also collect like
terms evaluate on the right hand side
what will the square be once it's nice
and factorized x yeah so watching out
that's sine there right it's a it's not
important when you complete a square but
it is important when you're factorizing
so it's going to be x minus 4 and then
what about the the y part y so so sorry
I'll get to the wait a second straight
you asked why is that minus 4 it comes
from that minus sign right there see
that that's got a negative there and go
ahead expand this you'll need this minus
sign to get the minus 8x okay and then
as you guys were just telling me Y plus
3 have you evaluated the right hand side
yet 36 so what's the radius of this
section it's the square root of that
right hand side okay so even though it
looks a bit messy you're just like I
don't have to complete the square once I
complete the square twice but it's not
not harder just it's an extra thing to
do so I'm gonna read off my Center is 4
and negative 3 and my radius is 6 as you
just told me note it ok